[Musique]
si le roi est ce qu'on apprentissage
garçons et filles sont à égalité c'est
ma première expérience avec dépit c'est
un petit peu prématuré évidemment pour
tirer une conclusion mais à mon avis il
n'y a aucune raison pour que cela ne
marche pas la preuve en cas de nécessité
vous savez on a besoin des femmes pour
faire tous les travaux possibles
pensons par exemple
ce qui s'est produit la dernière guerre
nous avons vu des femmes faisant toutes
sortes de métiers donc pourquoi pas la
mécanique moto entre autres
les mains de kiel femmes sont admirables
et toutes semblables à des oiseaux
l s'agit de leurs doigts millions ses
frères comme valisère de passereaux la
film catherine prud'homme 24 ans 1 m 50
45 kg diplôme bac c'est catherine vous
êtes menuisier non menuisière et depuis
8 quand est ce que vous avez décidé de
notre prendre cette carrière
disons que ça fait seulement un an et
demi que j'ai vraiment décidé de faire
de la menuiserie
alors j'ai cherché des stages de
formation un peu partout que j'ai écris
pas eu beaucoup de résultats
j'écris chez les compagnons ils prennent
pas de femmes
j'ai écrit et la seule réponse que j'ai
eu c'est du centre j'ai fait le stage le
pétain monsieur en stage de menuiserie
nous former aussi bien des hommes que
des femmes
est ce que vous faites une différence
dans l'enseignement dans l'enseignement
non c'est exactement le même travail que
les petits ponts
où les femmes comme les hommes et
ensuite au niveau du résultat les élèves
sont identiques à la sortie de ces 1 [ __ ]
sur elle même est exactement le même
résultat pour les filles
au sirop sinon meilleur que pour les
hommes et ensuite au niveau de l'emploi
il ya une différence l'emploi on a
toujours eu un problème pour tous place
et les jeunes filles ou les jeunes
femmes qui sortaient de chez nous un les
artisans qui emploie les ouvriers tic
toujours un peu pour employer une jeune
fille les jeunes panne alors que selon
vous n'y a aucune raison non pas du tout
moi je pense avoir rencontré des
difficultés dans la mesure où les gars
bricole toujours un petit peu je tire
dès qu'ils sont gosses on leur apprend
un peu à bricoler les filles en général
pas tellement c'est que c'est une autre
approche du travail s'est on a eu notre
démarche à faire
on voit mieux comment entamer un travail
est mené sa vie et vous avez eu des
difficultés pour trouver du travail
oh oui ça n'a pas été si possible que ça
d'ailleurs j'ai ressorti une lettre là
que le directeur de l'école a reçu
messieurs j'ai bien réfléchi
il est impossible que j'emploie votre
stagiaire je ne vois pas cette petite
demoiselle avoir suffisamment de
résistance aussi bien physique
qu'intellectuelle à l'école ce n'est
jamais difficile mais en atelier
artisanal c'est une autre chanson i'll
usine en série peut-être mais pas dans
le spécial je suis désolé je crois qu'il
est de votre devoir de prévenir cet
enfant avec ménagement
elle avait l'air d'y croire recevez
monsieur bon alors je m'appelle clown
prénom lagadec plomb j'ai 18 ans je
mesure 1 mètre 57 retraite 50 kg j'ai
les yeux marrons j'ai les cheveux bruns
avec une teinture en brousse je suis
peintre en bâtiment et je me spécialise
en collage
voilà non c'est vrai c'est bien ouais tu
me mets bien sûr les rethélois sur les
bords et qui n'ont là impeccable
j'ai fait une information de vendeuse ça
m'a pas pu j'ai fait la coiffure cenap a
promis si j'ai fait secrétariat deux ans
et ça m'a plus jamais passer quand bien
même si c'était un peu austère dans les
pattes
ta vie ta robe et comment ça s'est passé
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie d'abord
d'être peintre vous m'avez toujours
voulu faire j'étais un peu en le dans le
milieu ouvrier
et c'est cette ambiance que je
recherchais partout et n'est en fait pas
mal de formation j'ai jamais trouvé
cette ambiance à part en bâtiment donc
je l' ai préféré faire le bâtiment je
vous dit que vous aimez les chantiers
mais est ce qu'il n'ya pas de problème
je dire avec les hommes
ben moi j'ai pas eu de problèmes mais ça
peut créer des problèmes notamment pour
déshabiller des choses comme ça dépend
ils sont qui confère un finalement c'est
enfin nous des chantiers qui sont
presque terminée puisqu'on n'est pas un
trou noir et enfin un dernier pas
toujours parce que des fois on est les
premiers mais des fois ça posait des
problèmes mais enfin j'étais dans un
milieu assez sympathique et on s'est
toujours arrangé mais je dis pas pour
les autres ce sera pas pareil je sais
pas
ne pas descendre et du tout parce que
j'ai fait mon apprentissage il ya 40 ans
apple ferait je suis tombé avec trois
jeunes filles des trois fils du baron
qui l'a bien aidée ou blanc comme clown
ya une seule chose avec mon petit canard
où ils avaient dérobé barre alors pour
forcer les signes de peinture janice
semos l'enfant les koras hausse parce
que j'ai toujours essayé vraiment
courageuse c'est le foot notamment dont
les tempes et des chantiers comme ça
d'accord et non pas les teens de travail
ou de tarantino mais en tout cas et qui
fait son travail il pourra je lis une vo
de peindre et il est assez basse pour
faire ça une femme qui a peu moins fort
que l'autre doit pas dépasser un meuble
comme ça sinon ça l'était aussi des
hommes qui sont à fort que les autres
oui mais les hommes les hommes
comment vous êtes déplacé quelque chose
quoi
énergique suis d'accord que par exemple
- déplacer des mêmes là c'est vrai c'est
quand même un studio mais ça dépend
aussi des meubles
bon bah on peut toujours se faire aider
et qu'ici on peut pas d'harmonie de sur
un chantier j'en connais des femmes qui
se déplace à naama bien sûr il y en a il
y en a qui peuvent sauver des teens
équipes qui font plus que nous encore
qui sont encore plus forcément un mais
j'estime que le bâtiment il ya certes un
travail qu on peut se permettre de faire
pour les femmes que les femmes d arriver
à faire avant qu'il n'y a pas de force
s'est pas arrangé un coup d'épongé ça va
se passer à lèvres pour faire un plafond
le clou la faute
qu'est ce que ça coûte de bassins et
déposons plafond de fatigue les bras moi
je dis non pas que le plafond si facile
je regarde moi je regarde tout
l'ensemble ça va rater tout ça le par
c'est dur quand même c'est fini pour moi
tes propos
les moines pas imaginer puisque moi j'ai
tout neuf tout en rut moi c'est imaginer
quelle aurait pris deux de la force
oui ce pas ce que dit le second de 10 kg
après ce sera 15 à face ostrava
on s'amuse et on rend à son lot il ya
des femmes qui sont dans les pouilles
ce que je pense aussi
il y aurait dans le travail faire son
travail mais pas prendre du poids et
stéphane nathan fils est ce que vous
auriez envie que beaucoup de femmes
fassent comme vous de ne plus être la
pierre bien sûr parce que je peux être
la salle 1 et puis moi je me plais alors
pourquoi d'autres s'y plieraient pas au
contraire je suis sûr c'est qu'ici
perret
mais si ça c'est tellement dur 1,5
milieu qui est quand même assez dur même
si les ouvriers veulent travailler avec
les femmes
vous avez les patrons tous vous avez les
les syndicats qui veulent pas alors pour
traverser tout ça c'est dur une fois
qu'on est en étude milieu ouvrier c'est
ça va mais moi je voudrais je voudrais
qu'il y en ait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup
[Musique]